hey folks and welcome to realitycheck
now have you ever had a story of a game
spoiled for you take say the last of us
now it's not really a spoiler but you
know that bit we're main characters joel
and ellie
mushroom zombies
tea party
dumbledore appears
savage prolapse
oh mine
rob stark
turns out to be a dream
what wonderful storytelling
now in the universal book of wisdom
right under things everyone hates
alongside giant killer hornets traffic
wardens and fake bacon you can clearly
find spoilers
why well because they ruin a story right
well
maybe not a scientific study carried out
by uc san diego psychology department
published in the journal of
psychological science demonstrated that
perhaps spoilers aren't as bad as we all
think the researchers gave subjects 12
short stories by authors including
agatha christie roald dahl and john
updike some were presented in their
classical form while others included
spoilerific paragraphs inserted into
this story each version was read by at
least 30 test subjects and these people
were then asked to assess their
enjoyment of the story and you know what
the readers of the spoil stories
actually rated them more enjoyable
it seems crazy but the subjects even
preferred the spoiled versions of ironic
twist stories take the example of a
story where it was revealed before
reading that a condemned man's daring
escape is all just a fantasy in his head
before the news snaps tight around his
neck the same was also true for murder
mysteries
so why on earth should this be the case
well the researchers mused that perhaps
is because it's easier to read and
understand a spoiled story think about
it once you know the big twist it's
simpler to piece all the clues together
and keep track of the tale so does this
mean we should all just stop caring
about video game spoilers and hell maybe
even seek them out
well for me i'm not so sure because you
see while this study was really well put
together it's just not a great analogy
of how spoilers happen in real life most
important of all it didn't take into
account one huge factor
investment the subjects in the study had
no prior knowledge of which stories they
were going to be reading and i doubt
they'd spent the last few years
frantically waiting to hear what
happened next to inspector poirot no
disrespect to agatha christie but
compare that with say mass effect 3. now
relax i'm definitely not going to spoil
anything but it was the final chapter of
the commander shepard trilogy big things
were always going to happen now i
actually had the ending of mass effect 3
spoiled for me before i even started
playing the culprit online discussion
because of all the hubbub and discontent
from fans concerning the story's
conclusion
at the time that really pissed me off
not because of how the story ended
actually but because i was heavily
invested in this story i've been
anticipating the conclusion of commander
shepard's tale for years ever since i
completed mass effect 2 and me2 was and
remains one of my all-time favorite
games
furthermore rpgs like mass effect
require you to put a great deal of
yourself in the game because of this i
would argue they have the potential to
offer an even more personal experience
than a book add to that the time
investment by the time mass effect 3
came out i'd spent at least 40 hours
cruising the milky way with garrison co
add all this up and you get a heck of a
lot of emotional investment so
unsurprisingly a lot more anger and
frustration at finding out the end of
the story before you even start playing
this was my experience anyway and i was
so proud that i never actually got more
than seven hours into mass effect 3
before giving up such was my annoyance
but investment isn't the only thing i
think this study missed you see we also
need to think about the social context
you see spoilers don't happen in a
bubble or even as part of a story as
they did in this test they happen
outside of your control at the office
coffee machine on the bus or more often
than not online this can result in us
feeling like we have lost something that
we have somehow missed out and loss of
version psychology teaches us that we
actually feel twice as bad about losing
something when compared to the relative
joy of gaining something
so where does that leave us with
spoilers in video games
well we should perhaps learn from the
study that while spoilers can rightly
leave us angry annoyed and with a huge
sense of loss
if it does happen we shouldn't ever let
it stop us playing these games
regardless i mean ultimately the story
itself will never actually be ruined
and that's why over the next few weeks
i'm actually going to go back and play
mass effect 3 to the end and try and
enjoy the story for what it is
but what do you think have you ever had
any big games spoiled let me know in the
comments down below by leaving a spoiler
free comment or of course you can reach
out to me on twitter at camfrasrop
thanks for watching
it's not really a spoiler but you know
that bit where main characters joel and
ellie make friends with all the mushroom
zombies and then they have a huge tea
party and of course dumbledore appears
and then that results in them all having
a savage prolapse and then they go and
journey to that mine oh mine and who
should be down there but rob stark and
then they all board the train to king's
cross station but then they wake up and
it all turns out to be a dream
what wonderful storytelling